do you find the dark
unsettling have you ever watched the big
game
on your refrigerator with all the
conveniences of modern living
available in your pocket or at the press
of a button
you have to wonder what if earth
lost power for a week
could you communicate with the rest of
the world
how much would it cost to restore the
power
and would there be complete anarchy
this is what if and here's what would
happen if
earth lost power for seven days
in 2019 a massive power outage crippled
venezuela
leaving the south american country in
shambles
armed biker gangs roamed the streets
policing the citizens at gunpoint
hospitals were left without power and
ransacked supermarkets were left bare
but what if the power went out worldwide
and stayed off for a week would our
global infrastructure collapse too
the united states energy information
agency estimates that
in 2015 humans used about
575 quadrillion british thermal units of
energy
with about 7.3 billion people on earth
that's enough energy for each of us to
have
78 million btus so
if a geomagnetic storm swept our entire
planet
there's no doubt there would be massive
upheaval of social norms
this event dubbed a black sky hazard
would take out all our communication
networks
the storm caused by coronal mass ejected
from the sun
would propel electromagnetic energy at
our planet
at the speed of light the excited
particles in the upper atmosphere would
disrupt
radio signals used by satellites you
wouldn't be able to contact your
friends and relatives who live further
away
your cell phone may be fully charged but
without an active network you'd
essentially be
holding a paperweight in the beginning
you might not even realize that the
outage is global
you may even enjoy the first night since
there wouldn't be any electronic
distractions and you'd have a clear view
of the night sky but there would be a
cost
30 minutes after the initial hit a wave
of electrons and protons would follow
damaging the electronic circuits in
satellites
this deadly dose of radiation could also
threaten
astronauts in orbit or passengers
in high-flying aircraft many of our
satellites need
space flight operators on earth to
control their courses
with no one at the helm satellites could
crash into space debris
or each other meanwhile back on earth
hospitals could face catastrophic
effects from the power outage
the energy currents produced by a
geomagnetic storm
could induce power lines to destabilize
the grid's operation this massive surge
could destroy transformers around the
world
the best backup generators are only able
to provide about
24 hours of power so intensive care
units across the world
would suffer tremendous losses
ventilators wouldn't function
and medical staff would have to use
manual devices like
rubber lungs to keep patients alive
people who need dialysis
would go without it and doctors would
have to make difficult choices
about people's lives and
power plants across the world would fail
whether they're fueled by coal natural
gas or nuclear fission
it could take days or even weeks to
restore them to full capacity
the cooling systems of nuclear reactors
would fail
and total nuclear meltdowns would happen
it could take weeks to restore europe's
massive interconnected power grid
which supplies energy to over 24
countries
and 400 million customers
and none of this includes the cost in
dollars
assuming that we'd still be using money
once the power comes back
when two million customers in california
lost power
for two days the u.s department of
energy estimated
it cost the economy around two and a
half
billion dollars according to the u.s
department of energy
33 percent of american businesses could
lose
twenty thousand to five hundred thousand
dollars
with the banks shut down you wouldn't be
able to access
the cash in your accounts let's hope you
kept a little savings in your piggy bank
but the stores have
limited stocks of items and without cash
registers and
payment systems things could get ugly
fast
the masses could grow restless and take
these essential items by force
if it means keeping their families alive
so with chaos raining in the streets
could you drive away to the woods well
unless your car has a full tank
you won't be getting far gas pumps
wouldn't be functioning
traffic lights wouldn't work and the
roads could turn into a demolition derby
but it's not just your car at risk
thousands of people would be stranded
underground in subways
if you were flying airports would have
24 hours to land the planes before their
backup generators quit
the world's transportation industry
would be crippled
and unable to deliver needed supplies
and depending on where you live there's
more than
a lack of supplies that should worry you
it's the sudden stoppage of services
emergency services
couldn't take your calls people stuck in
elevators couldn't call for help
and without furnaces supplying heat
people in colder areas would have to
rely on burning wood or
a tight snuggle to stay warm and
without power the pumps in the water
towers wouldn't work
so many areas would suffer devastating
water shortages
you would have to conserve your water
carefully because
there's only so much left in the tanks
to distribute
each glass of water would drain our
supply
the electric sewage systems couldn't
pump away waste so
every flush could wreak havoc on your
plumbing
this could cause an overflow of waste
that
backs up into your home and that's not
the only thing that's going to wreak
on day 2 the perishable items in your
fridge
will start to expire and without
garbage pickups these rotting items
would pile up in the streets
with so many of our services dependent
on electricity
a geomagnetic storm wouldn't just leave
us bored without social media
it could leave us stinky starving
and desperate and while this event might
seem unthinkable to you according to the
world bank
there are 1 billion people living
without
electricity and hundreds of millions
live with
unreliable or expensive power keeping
several developing nations in the dark
to combat this some experts are working
to develop
artificial intelligence that could
predict power outages
and there's still a lot of research to
be done on
how to make renewable energy sources
more reliable for
mass consumption but maybe you're tired
of
living in this modern nightmare and want
to live
completely off the grid what if
you lived in a closed biosphere
well that's a story for another
what if
you